one of the coolest spots to visit at san
diego comic-con is a sideshow
collectibles booth you saw us taking a
tour of it earlier and now we've got
Mike tolentino here from Sideshow
Collectibles with his buddy nathan drake
and mike thanks for coming by and
bringing a friend thank you for having
us it was it was fun it was an adventure
getting here Nathan always gets lost we
have our Nathan Drake Premium Format
figure available at sideshow com this is
a cool figure because it's got the full
the full cloth costume and he's from
head to toe he's got the pants on yeah
the thermal you can float you can have
tuck that thing in the begin just for
swag yeah he's got the swagger that that
is quintessential Drake look yes he's
got his little is it a scarf for when
he's chili and his band dealers are all
it's all leather it's all hands that you
can see the thread lines everything's
really cool really well put together and
you could put this on like you were
putting this together earlier on I hope
you don't mind me calling you I I
totally mess it up you had the bed
earlier on the wrong way we'll check the
image and is like whoa whoa ya gotta get
up yeah often to size me yeah but yeah
so we you can dress it you can coord
customize it if you don't want as man
purse on he can take his man purse off
or Stachel if you will but yeah so
satchel it's a good or manners but yeah
it's so it's you can do it in a lot of
different ways he also has a switch out
hand god you can pull that off you put
his pistol in you can take his pistol
out of his holster there so it's there's
a lot of different options we try to
make it so you can have fun with your
statute it's not just it's not just a
static yeah thing you know I mean it
goes on your mantelpiece next to your
picture of your family ya know their
cherished I guess it's the family
grandparents Drake yeah and in that
order you know we got we got to have
some perspective and yeah this is going
to we're trying to do we don't just want
guys that are standing still we want to
make our statutes or leap out and he's
literally leaping over this wall at you
and it's good it's just a really dynamic
piece and we're we're giving away here
yes our yeah that's the that's the extra
exciting thing is that you can win this
all you gotta do is go on Twitter
gamespot just tweeted a giveaway tweet
there it is I'll have to do is read
tweet that this weekend on Monday will
be picking the winner and giving this
away to a UH a happy and healthy home
fortunately because you know Nate has
seen a lot of stuff yes he needs a good
solid home yeah some love imported leave
some water out for him mmm he gets
thirsty with all the mantling yes and
the fling the scarf hither and yon very
cool Mike uh but you know you guys have
a huge booth at the show floor as well
as a bunch of new stuff you're showing
off at san diego comic-con time yes what
about that sideshow collectibles booth
1929 we're showing tons of new stuff
right now our DC statues that we're
revealing we have our Batgirl which is
brand new Power Girl and the Lobo which
is cool Lobos about this big he has a
companion pieces dog which is a
roided-out pitbull bulldog nice um and
he's got two heads he's got to switch
out seven Bosley head to make it more or
the classic and then he's got these cool
dreadlock space dreadlocks it's
fantastic space dreadlocks space
dreadlock told you had had me a spacer
about it switch out hand with the with
the flaming skull he's kind of sickle is
just really cool and leather work or are
cutting so team really really puts that
dynamic touch to it because it just adds
a different layer to use that term
earlier cut and sew team so like give me
that give me the structure of like what
different teams so you've got a
different team for the the cloth you got
a team for other elements so first we
start off on design and then we'll break
down to a sculpt so they'll digitally do
it but with zbrush although get big hunk
of clay and sculpt it by hand and then
from there we mold it out and then it
goes to our paint team and our cutting
so tuned so the paint teams will paint
all the different parts of it yeah
that's how you get the five o'clock I've
been lost in the desert exactly shadow
yeah and then are cutting so team will
put together the costume on a body and
we'll send that out to make sure we can
get the right material so he has that
dingy dirty look to his clothes it's not
just brand new continents I mean you can
see it's all just detailed and weathered
and he looks gross you look he looks
like he smells it's get a nice nice butt
shot there we go what have you goodnight
tucked yep get the half tuck
totally so no [ __ ] stamp so you've got
so you get it to get it together and
then do you have to sort of consult with
naughty dog or sony IM not a dog they
they work with this almost from the
beginning as far as approving the
concept and then making sure that we
represent what it is they want to share
it trick for them cool so you know
obviously Sony Naughty Dog you guys have
worked with DC you've done a ton of work
with but that's not the limit of no not
chocolate yeah we also have marble we
just actually revealed some marvelous
excuse which were really excited about
those are the articulated 12-inch
figures okay six scale what that means
that they're 66 yeah 16 so if you were
your one scale yep so if we did a
quarter scale of you it'd be this guy
and then if we did a six Calvary you're
not at all yeah but a foot tall 30
points of articulation and we just
revealed that the show our dead pole and
our world rain figure and those both are
amazing they're what's cool about these
is we're taking a little bit of license
artistic license of how they're designed
so these aren't designs that you've seen
before in comics ah the Wolverine
actually has like like a brown leather
look to him and he's got these cool
gauntlets on his forearm so he there
we're doing a little bit beaten off the
beaten path that's really interesting
because I mean within comics of course
we've all seen superheroes have umpteen
costumes exactly what incarnation of the
hero it is but for you guys to get to
sort of put your own creative spin on
yeah it's time pretty cool yeah the
creative team has a blast doing there I
mean we're all fans to the properties
and we all have ideas of what they
should be and how they should look so
it's a combination of just everyone's
working together which it's always a
great end product and we were talking
earlier speaking of the sort of that
creativity you guys are really getting
to flex that now with your new thing you
guys yes taken off yeah the court of the
Dead Court of the dead calm that is her
own IP source our own independent
property and it is incredible the story
is heaven how have been waging war for
ever and mankind souls are trapped in
the middle so death is tired of it and
he decides he's almost like the
professor x of the underworld
he starts taking all these holes and
gathering his his quarter the dead to
rise up and overthrow heaven hill the
motto is rise conquer rule and there's
three factions so there's flesh bone and
spirit exactly it's kind of gross a
little gross but kind of cool but you
need all three two surviving is your
fleshy ninja bone you spirit naturally
that's and I it's exactly science we've
all we all learned it and they all work
together and it's almost a game of
thrones in the underworld because
there's a lot of political intrigue and
backstabbing not only do we have these
statues that were putting out but we
have a graphic novel in the works we
have a possible video games in the works
we're really spreading it out to get
this property and everyone's been super
excited about the show if you're at the
show come to the booth there's a full
like circus tent in the middle of our on
the middle of the booth floor and you
can see all the future offerings that
we're going to have of core the dead
neat now that's I mean it seems like you
guys Sideshow Collectibles you have this
creative team that is you know
responsible for taking what a still
image of Nathan Drake or maybe a 3d
model and turning it into this a big
dynamics that you've got the creative
engine there and you know that
interpretation it must just be pretty
friggin cool for the artist to get so it
is under things out of there and they
can go unchecked too which is great
because we don't have to be bound by
like we said we love working with non
your dog and Star Wars and Marvel and DC
yeah but to be able to play in our own
sandbox yeah it's super fun just because
it's everyone's flexing their creative
juices and it's the product speaks for
themselves you can tell it's a labor of
love and so it's not just going to be an
assortment of figures or statues it's
going to be a graphic novel graphic
novel in the works we might even do
different formats of the figure so
they're right now they're all quarter
scale but they might if the if the
interest warrants they could go to
12-inch figures they can go to life size
bust we have some so we have a lot of
things planned it just depends where the
momentum takes us sure depends yeah sort
of what catches on and where you guys
sort of feel like you want to go with it
do you have a favorite among the the
court of the dead there's a figure
called all avail which is the
executioner mm-hmm and he's got it's
disgusting he's got these little fingers
over his
under coming under his chin and he's got
this dog that we called dog level and
it's got human hands four paws the dog
has super creeper pause super creepy and
then there's the Red Death which it's
the guy home the management is what we
call it cuz he's just holding his energy
it's okay yes more and I think that was
a design work yeah that was the art
direction but you and they'll they all
look great and they look like I said
everyone's the feedback on it has been
super positive so we're really excited I
take it back it's horrifying that you
guys are taking your creative license
yeah it's a little bit scary that that's
what comes out of us I'm a little
frightened but very cool for you guys at
sideshow collectibles and if folks are
interested in court of the Dead they can
check yet more stuff out where the det
cord of the dead calm we're also having
a number of Giveaways this year we're
doing if you go to court dead calm you
could win the queen of the Dead if you
go to side show.com slash win solo you
could win the life-size one-to-one han
Solo life-sized life-size 121 so about
that so if you have someone living with
you you have to have them move to the
pause or yeah on solo requires a bedroom
he does yeah a themed bedroom we're
giving away a Hulk statue from the
Avengers so that's sideshow calm / smash
mm-hmm that's the maquette from the
Avengers and we're giving away Harlequin
so that one I believe is sideshow calm /
Harley and so you guys you actually sell
these things too that we do yeah you do
give away we spent all this time and we
just hand them out like candy no yes I
showed outcomes are it's our main
website it's it's our blog it's our
store we sell direct to customers you
can also buy the metra local comic book
stores if they carry them yeah but yeah
the the stores the customer service team
as saj was great they'll help you out we
have flex pay so when you can't afford
it we can just take your money a little
bit at a time very accommodating yeah be
Mike oh it's very generous we're givers
it's what we do we give you yeah
opportunities to give us money in
exchange for this cool stuff and of
course Nathan Drake you guys are 100
yeah is one of the giveaways and we're
doing it through gamespot through the
generosity of folks here at sideshow all
you have to do is get on twitter follow
gamespot and fine
that tweet about the giveaway retweet it
this weekend and we'll be picking the
winner on Monday Mike tolentino thank
you so much for coming on by thanks
Chris thank you guys for the for the
Drake we're gonna enjoy him a happy home
and sideshow calm quarter dead calm
check it out folks thank you